my name is Oscar Robles I'm the
cinematographer for the undone today I
how to talk about the general look that
we're going to be going forward in the
undone the main goal that we're trying
to get with this movie is the old kind
of 70s classic textured atmospheric look
that we have in the old Robert Altman
movies candy tie is kind of doing that
recently Conrad Hall I you know he is a
master using light and just given it a
sense of atmosphere and it's for the
most part a lot of people don't really
hit that these days when they're using
digital cameras you know we we get this
kind of very very sharp look this kind
of very digital look I'm using the air
quotes here so we're gonna be shooting
on the c300 due to the that you know the
the nature of the shoe we're going to be
in the woods a lot and we're gonna be
using a lot of natural light so because
of that we like to see 304 it's low
light features and its general
robustness and the kind of run gun
nature that we can we can have with that
should we should we need that also less
people required to handle that camera it
is much easier for me myself or an
assistant to kind of just carry
everything and just go as opposed to
having like a whole unit you know around
that camera so to mitigate the general
sharp digital-look that we're trying to
go for we're using some old classic new
poor lenses these these were classic
Prime's back in the day and
state-of-the-art and you can still get a
really sharp image with these with the
added texture I just love to use that
word but we're going to get this classic
look using that glass and on top of that
is just that we're not going to really
have any any kind of extra fancy fancy
gear on the inside of these lenses today
we try to compensate for any kind of
movement with the image stabilization
and what you'd get with that is you have
to add more element
and little little techno gizmos stuff
inside the lens and so if you you know
you don't want to really shake that lens
this thing not not that you should you
could shut it down the street and it'll
be fine you know as long as the glasses
and damage so anyways today's lenses
tend to kind of give you a hamburger
light like a hamburger meat while these
old classic crimes and just Prime's in
general will give you a like a steak so
the quality of light is basically i'm
trying to say the quality of light is
phenomenal so you're getting a much
cleaner image to play with and that's
before it actually gets the sensor so
the quality of light hitting your sensor
is dramatically better so these nikkor
lenses have between four to eight
elements as opposed to like 12 to some
even have like 18 or 22 so it's it's
it's also beneficial to most independent
filmmakers because you can flat out on
these lenses for 100 dollars if you find
a good deal on ebay you know so when
you're trying to you know a lot of
people are trying to cut corners in
their budget and independent films and
to the detriment of the general
production this is one way where you can
cut back and actually debatably improve
the quality of your actual image so I
for me there was just a no-brainer nique
or lenses c300 and just playing with
natural light to kind of go for that
classic 70s kind of beautiful grime look
that we had back then and yeah I'm
looking I'm looking forward to film in
the undone every choice I feel really
confident about there is no other way to
get this look short of actually getting
film